[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
52. yep is that right 52 we
are closing in days away from a
presidential election
and i have to say i am guardedly
optimistic oh wow okay for what that we
will make it to the election
mm-hmm that uh that you and i the
country
all of us all of us i'm not saying i
will actually reach tuesday i'm saying
i think the chances are are are fairly
good we will make it to tuesday intact
after that all bets are off but uh yeah
tuesday i think is a high probability
all right all right i'm not sure exactly
uh what else to say
except for the fact that things seem uh
awfully precarious
and they really do um and i think we
will we may come back on wednesday with
another live stream
uh depending on what is known what we
think is known
the various uh values of known-ness uh
in
the universe as of wednesday morning i
have a suggestion
yes we call it a still a live stream
okay
all right i think we could call it that
regardless of when we came back but
um fair point i do think that uh it's
worth spending a little time
with talking about what's happening in
our in our neck of the woods and
also saying something about how portland
just how portland feels
at the moment uh because i spent a
couple of
partial days this last week just walking
around downtown
just trying to just i just went to see
what it felt like and it feels
like everyone is holding their breath
it's of course
much more empty than it would normally
be in a non-coveted 19 year
but beyond that how to what can you
attribute the emptiness
obviously some of it has to do with the
protests and riots
and um for a little while there in
september it had to do you know it was
completely empty i assume because
we like i think everyone else was
effectively locked in their homes
because of smoke
but uh and you know most of the downtown
businesses at this point are boarded up
even the ones that have not declared
that they are shuttered uh permanently
although many have
uh there is you know there is the usual
graffiti and garbage some of which is
really unpleasant
and the homeless people who i
saw and actually interacted with this
last week
were reminded me more of the homeless
people of 10 years ago
than some of the people who feel like
newcomers who've been uh
increasingly showing up on the streets
here but it really
felt like it felt like
no one could tell what was going on and
basically you know you're
you're ridiculous prediction that will
make it to tuesday
is how people are living at the moment
yeah it's uh it's stunning and it really
is there is a feel to it and i think
you know one of the things we've
discovered over uh
many discussions with people in remote
places is that we really have
no good way unless we deliberately check
in
with how does it feel in florida in
michigan
so uh when you say remote places you
mean like in the outback
like by remote i mean remote from you
so for for anyone trying to understand
what it feels like to be on the ground
in place x
uh you actually to some degree i mean
this this is the value
in the absurdly weaponized term lived
experience right you know what what what
is it
to actually be there and and see with
your own eyes and experience with all of
your other senses
uh what life is like in florida or
venice or wherever well i think i'm
actually pointing to almost the opposite
premise
okay which is that when people say lived
experience
right they can say well you may have all
the data in the world on what it's like
to be black in america
but you there's nothing you can do that
substitutes for my you know where i
black my lived experience right
right and of course there's one way in
which this is undeniable and there's
another way in which
we don't even know what your lived
experience means because we don't know
what kinds of biases went into
formulating it we don't know
how representative it is we don't know
you know any of the things that you
would want to know it's not data
which doesn't mean it doesn't contain
something but in this case
what i'm increasingly noticing you know
sort of generally in the internet age
but increasingly as we go
quite obviously mad the fact that one
has no basis to assume that something
that you would normally assume that
other people had seen
and felt together is actually a shared
experience yes right you have to check
in
and so yeah actually that yeah that that
fits very well with some
some of the places we want to go here
today yeah it's just it's a it's a key
thing because if you don't
if you just are on autopilot and your
sense you know
the problem is it's born of a very
normal assumption
that is in general rock solid right if
you're standing with somebody somewhere
and you're looking at something the
chances that they can see it too
are very very high right unless it's
very tiny and difficult for you to
perceive in which case you would
you would know that you had to say ah
it's right over there by the thing
well i mean i think this points to at
least two things one is
the necessity of intact
and um you know deeply nuanced theories
of mind
right like humans are not the only
organisms that have theory of mind which
is to say
the ability to attribute to someone else
a different understanding of reality or
a different emotional state or a
different
you know understanding of yeah well a
different understanding of reality
really
than what you yourself have there i've
mentioned here before
the excellent book baboon metaphysics by
the two primatologists dorothy chaney
and
um richard seaforth robert saveworth
junior and seyfarth
a married couple who spent a lot of time
in botswana and okavango river delta
studying these baboons
who find terrific evidence for theory of
mind and baboons and of course it's been
noted in crows in i think dolphins and
certainly elephants and wolves and
parrots so a number of these these other
groups all of which independently evolve
an ability
to ascertain that that which you believe
is not necessarily that which i believe
right and we also there's you know a
number of developmental psychology
studies
uh that point to when when it is in a
child's life
uh they tend to begin to develop a
theory of mine i don't actually remember
when that moment is something before two
years for sure but it may be well well
before that
well it does it's not fully developed
until much
later and so there sure sure series of
elaborate experiments which are
you're alluding to here in which you
know you can you know a child
who's old enough to speak you can ask
them
to tell you what it is that someone else
will have seen and then you by adjusting
when it is that that person entered and
left the room
and so an adult would know oh they
didn't see that development
yeah you can tell yeah actually i'm not
sure the two-year mark
i don't i don't remember you're right
that is sort of the sliding scale
of uh nuance in theory of mind and
um i think part of our confusion our
sort of global or humanity-wide
confusion right now at least for those
with the internet
which is basically all of you know the
subset of humanity
with whom all of us and you
watching and listening are engaging with
are pretty much people who
are um have access to the internet is
that the internet
to a greater degree even than tv which
came before it but tv did this as well
because it shows you real people uh you
imagine that they are you know they are
part of your social group
right that they are part of your social
group and they therefore have been
sharing sharing the same things and
knowing the same things as everyone else
and so we
we sort of drop some of the usual
um requirements for theory of mind when
we assume well like
you're part of my group therefore i know
that you and i have seen the same thing
we might disagree on what it means but
at least we have
a shared a common experience and no it's
not true
it's not true and i think you and i see
this in particular because
we have people who are showing up to to
talk with us mostly virtually but also
whom we're talking with in real life who
are coming from really
you know across the political spectrum
right like so
so we have people who see any critique
of of trump as evidence of trump
derangement syndrome
and we have people who see any evidence
of the protests that become riots
as evidence of uh of secretly
cryptically loving trump and
it seems like never the twin shall meet
but we can actually
see that one of the commonalities there
is you actually have
literally seen different things that
we've seen like in
in your feeds in your in in your life
and
in your media feeds you are literally
being shown
and told and uh and that that those two
things are also collapsed
the showing and the telling is being
collapsed into a single point by most
media including most journalists such
that
um you know the the analysis is wrapped
into the showing such that you can't
untangle it
and dangle it is um
a novel kind of bias that i think we
haven't
yet named and i think the problem here
like with many of these
novel modern phenomena is that it is
partly conscious and partly emergent
and so because it is these two things
you know to the extent that you sound
like you're alleging a conspiracy to
you know to edit down to one set of
facts you sound like a crazy person and
you know to the extent that you think
well you know you know i saw it on my
feed
it's not fake the point is you're naive
and the right
there the truth is really subtle in one
way
which is that we have algorithms
first of all we have publishers that
appear to have suspended
the most basic journalistic rules
and i think they think they've done it
temporarily i think they think well this
is just such a dire circumstance that
you know we're going to forego you know
and it's a little bit like the argument
for um for lockdown
right the argument for lockdown is look
civil liberties are really
important this is a novel contagious
dangerous phenomenon for which we need
to temporarily
you know change our uh our ordering of
the priorities
and the fact is i think there's a great
argument for that it doesn't mean it's
not being deployed cynically
right right and the problem is that the
platforms
and the publishers are now adjusting
the fabric of reality and because they
think they're doing it intentionally for
a good reason
they have completely lost track and lost
control of the degree to which they are
changing the necessary parameters for
even building a basic model of reality
oh and this it's
it's a particularly human maybe not it's
a particularly
any kind of organism with with theory of
mind and technology
and that's not purely limited to humans
but we've obviously
taken it to a greater degree than anyone
else kind of
of arrogance that imagines
that that doesn't understand
chesterton's fence again an idea that
we've come back to and back to and back
to in this in this
livestream and as we talk about a lot in
our book uh the idea that when you come
upon a fence and you don't know what
it's for
but it's irritating to you for some
reason
you should not be allowed to get rid of
it unless until
you can at the very least bare minimum
come to understand why the people who
put it there put it there what is its
intended use it's possible it has
outgrown its use
right it is possible it no longer has
the utility that it had or that it was
put up
um with good intentions and it's doing
something bad or that it was
an error in the first place and was put
up with bad intentions all of those
things are possible
but when you find such a structure you
don't get rid of it
without first trying to understand what
it is there for in the first place
and frankly a lot of modern psychology
makes this
makes this air a lot of modern medicine
makes us fair you know we just
over and over and over again but you
know what you're speaking to with regard
to well
you know and you and i were you know
have been
advocates for for the lockdown in order
to deal
with the virus especially early on um
but it does come with this risk that
once you take some civil liberties away
how do you get them back right and in
fact the chesterton's fence thing
is canonically going to run up against
every counter-intuitive right
right counter-intuitive rights by their
very nature
are a version of chesterton's fence you
inherit free speech you don't know what
it's good for because you haven't seen
the alternative and it seems like you
know what's really irritating
some of these terrible things that
people say we really don't want to hear
them anymore i really don't want to hear
these terrible there's some truly viable
vile stuff being said right and and you
know in this case i think
not only don't i want to hear them but i
don't want you to hear them because it's
bad for you it's bad for you
yeah right and the thing is everybody
gets that including the people who
formulated these rights
right right they formulated them because
there was a higher principle and until
you've
lived with the absence of this freedom
you don't really understand
why you should be tolerating vile speech
and the answer is because not tolerating
it eliminates speech you need to hear
but is
heterodox or counterintuitive or or
whatever
and actually let me just say too you
know that the some of the
frankly naive pushback that i'll hear to
the little
sarcastic spoofing we were just doing of
the anti-free speech people
uh is well you know why don't you why
don't you then object to
uh to obscuring what's available to
children
well children are children and it is
exactly the adults roles and
specifically parents roles
to protect children until they are of an
age where they can actually make
decisions and choices for themselves and
when is that and how is that and
you know these are all judgment calls
that we should be having conversations
about as a society
but certainly within the family um that
is
um that is an expectation that children
are protected from some things
um you know as the more so earlier on
and but there was one other thing i was
going to say to that but i don't
remember
well nonetheless actually maybe this is
a good place it's out of order here
but we are losing track of things you
know as as
douglas murray says things we knew until
yesterday
right so i ran into uh
maybe many of you have seen it on
twitter noam chomsky was interviewed by
the new yorker
recently uh yeah like in the last few
days zach could you put up
uh the article
there he is there's gnome uh this is
noam chomsky and he
says in this article and i will say i
didn't read the article through but i
certainly did track down this
claim to make sure that it wasn't being
misrepresented he said
that trump is the worst criminal in
human history
i would point out this is noam chomsky
and he and the to the journalists credit
he and the journalists tangle over
whether that could possibly be defended
and the journalist points out that in
order to reach this
you have to make a number of uh leaps
including
you have to obliterate the idea of
intent being relevant
and chomsky says in the interview he
doesn't care basically his claim here is
that he's the worst criminal
in human history because the things he's
doing put us in jeopardy which is a
nonsense claim that a guy like
chomsky ought to certainly know better
than to say but
certainly i would have like i i won't
comment on the article because i have
not read it
i didn't know it existed but if if as
you say
the headline is pulled correctly from
chomsky's actual beliefs that does
truly point to the ridiculous moment
that we're living in
when people will make a claim you know
one of the most important left voices
alive today
could make a claim like that right
especially in you know the thing that
chomsky would be expected to be
excellent
at is the recognition that both sides
were putting us in tremendous jeopardy
and that ultimately one needs to escape
this and so i must say i was
completely shocked by his endorse
endorsement of biden
because of chopsticks yeah because you
know pick your existential threat right
it's two different versions of
catastrophe
and a guy like chomsky is exactly the
sort of person who traditionally
when he's on his game says yes actually
the system does
this right and here in this case he's
just sided with one
group and he's put on blinders and it's
the same thing
we've seen from you know bernie sanders
and
frankly andrew yang and you know it's
it's incredible how many people regard
something
about trump as requiring them to
surrender the very capacity for nuance
that made each of them special
yeah um you know i wasn't i wasn't on
social media
and i wasn't paying attention to any of
these types of conversations
throughout the obama presidency and
we as we have said before were huge fans
of obama and excited about him at the
point that he was
running the first time and really felt
like things could be turning around and
in some
truly positive ways in 2008 and
i by the time 2012 rolled around
reluctantly voted for him a second time
and i don't you didn't even vote for him
a second time
so um we are we are not here as
people who were uh you know blind to the
disappointments
of the president that brought the most
hope in our lifetime anyway
um but i have you know i've heard and
i've not dug into
the history of the bile on the right
against obama
and um i think you know i i know it
existed
and i don't know what its tone was i
don't know what its tender was i know
some of it was compl
fabulously disgusting um but
i don't what i don't know is was it a
mere image
of of this with regard to the left's
feeling about trump
and i i just don't know the answer to
that well
you know it's a great question and the
problem you know i've been
forced by the bad behavior of people i
once respected
to go back and try to rethink
how i ended up concluding what i had
about them and whether i was in fact
blind
yeah and right you know in obama's case
i'm pretty sure i wasn't
i mean there was definitely at the point
before he had been elected and i
actually believed that he
stood an excellent chance of changing
things and that he would change them
in a positive direction
i was clearly missing something and i
still don't know what it was i still
don't know
if obama is not who we thought he was if
he
is who we thought he was but something
that we cannot see
blocked him uh or i don't know what the
explanation is but
in which case if he is what we thought
he was and something blocked him then
how can you imagine that any president
could affect change in the in the united
states at this point right and in fact
this is one of the arguments
that people deploy in various ways in
favor of trump which is that because
he's
truly not of this system he is true he
wasn't until four years ago well right i
mean that's my point is yes
he muscled in on their action which is
at least a novel storyline but it's not
a
positive change right it's a new it's a
new crime family on the scene
you know given as good as it gets from
the old crime families
or to the old crime families but uh so i
don't know
where i miss things but i do know that i
mean even the fact that i didn't vote
for obama a second time
i didn't vote for him because i was wide
awake
to his failure to be what we expected
and hoped he would be
and to all of the things he did that i
thought were
jaw-dropping and dangerous so but i i
was
paying attention and i i didn't get what
what you are asking about and you were
on social media during that time
i was yeah um
but i guess i i really i do
wonder how new this
thing that we're seeing with regard to
the inability
to deal with anything that trump does
other than the fact that it's trump from
the left
has been mirrored um on the right with
regard to obama
and you know if we go back eight more
years
um to bush two
no one in our sphere whom we were
talking politics to at that point was
a big fan of bush too uh but
there it wasn't like this right it was
not like this
at all and so i don't know if things
changed with the right's response to
obama
or if the left's response to trump is
actually a sea change
a a truly novel situation uh
that is marking something that frankly
if if this is
if this is as new as it feels to me not
having seen not having been privy to
what might have been going on
on the right with regard to their hatred
of obama uh then
that points to even greater worries to
me about instability that is that is
brewing right now
right i think i think what we are those
of us who are tracking
the meta phenomenon yeah right the
inconsistency between things that were
once reconcilable
right right those of us who are tracking
that
are i think alarmed because it's a
little bit like
um i don't know what's the right analogy
maybe it's um
why am i blanking on his name uh the uh
mathematician a schizophrenic
mathematician
a beautiful mind uh uh anyway it'll come
back to me but
here you had a highly intelligent person
who became aware that he
was perceiving um reality
in a fiercely broken way and you know to
his credit was able to sort of
build a correction so that
that thing didn't interfere with his
ability to do
um nash um to do
what he uh was on earth effectively to
do
right to sort out stuff like nash
equilibria and other
yeah interfered with plenty else in his
life right but the point is if you know
that your brain plays those tricks on
you i actually think this is one of the
important values of um of psychedelics
is that if you can knowingly
engage some of the things that your
brain will do
under those circumstances then you're a
little better prepared when things go
haywire for whatever reason yeah whether
endogenously or exogenously
right but um but in any case those of us
who are
tracking the meta-narrative are i think
beginning to be aware that we are
watching something
that is not just an analogy to
collective psychosis
but this is a very real process and it
really
you know like imagine that
social media has paranoid schizophrenia
at the moment
and then say well how much does that
explain about the discussions that i'm
watching
uh oh unfortunately uh way more than
would be healthy
and jeez what's tied up in this um you
know
pandemic policy nuclear codes you know
economic collapse our view of race
and all of the progress that we've made
on it over the last couple hundred years
and isn't i mean paranoid schizophrenia
it which you know itself may be
a bunch of things you know with
different ideologies and you know we're
not
we're no psychologists but um i think
it is actually in some way one of its
many features
is it's a failure of it inherently
involves a failure theory of mind
because there is additional narrative
going on at least sometimes
in the head of the person and they have
to imagine
um that as they are spouting nonsense to
someone else that that someone else is
also sharing their delusions
and so um this this is a breakdown
of this again you know not unique to
humans but one of the fundamental
you know superpowers of humans which is
attributing different mental states to
others
theory of mind right and actually you
know maybe the solution here
which i think we're a long way from but
we need to bootstrap it and
quick um the solution borrows
from interpersonal experience right
those
rare interpersonal experiences that
actually mirror
this exact breakdown where two people
diverge in their ability to see
even what narrative they they share
together yeah and the point is that
results
in you know literally being triggered
you know
uh in this way that makes the other
person the enemy and all of this and
so to the extent that the real point is
you know what
i don't know what you're seeing on your
feed but i'm just going to make the
assumption i know you to be reasonable
therefore i'm going to assume that the
crazy things that i hear you saying
are the logical result of what you
actually think is going on and that the
divergence
between what you think is going on and
what i think is going on is in some
sense
exogenous yeah and you know i do wonder
i know there have been
some experiments but i do wonder why
those of us
who recognize the hazard here are not
obsessed with reverse engineering as
much of the algorithmic stuff as we can
including why are we not
paired with somebody who the algorithm
sees as our opposite
so that we can exchange information on
what reality looks like through that
lens just as a corrective
yeah i mean i do this informally
yeah i'm checking in with stuff i'm not
supposed to be reading because that
tells me something of what other people
are seeing
but there ought to be a systematic way
to do it and
um i don't i don't at least see a
wholesale effort at it and it really
needs to happen now i remember actually
our friend jordan hall
formerly jordan green hall saying to us
gosh it must have been five six
years ago that he was he specifically
made a point of going
deep and you're not just surface level
not sort of just you know fox versus
msnbc but
deep into the the chance basically of
both sides to see what was
being believed and what was being
trotted out as fact
well fascinating you should mention
jordan because
guess what happened to jordan this week
oh he got booted from facebook
facebook amazing oh my goodness so my
conjecture here
is actually that there is some some of
you will be familiar with him from uh
blue church red church discussions
yep yeah um or rebel wisdom
yeah he's done a number of rebel wisdom
interviews but fabulous thinker and he's
got some amazing essays on medium as
well he does but i think the thing is
the um thing that tossed me off facebook
and has now tossed him and a bunch of
other people were tossed too and i don't
know who they were i'm not paying real
close attention to facebook but
um the thing that i think is the
thread that joins us is
you've got people who are not
dismissible as conservatives
right if you're a you know a gop
conservative then i don't think facebook
is all that worried about you because
at some level you can be dismissed by
those who need to
ignore the things that you're saying
you're already wearing the star
right yeah there you go the real
problematic cases are the ones who
aren't buying this woke stuff that is
taking over these institutions
but can't be dismissed as conservatives
for whatever reason are either too
heterodox or too liberal or something
like that because
that is the thing that breaks the damn
narrative and so
yeah we need they they need ideologues
in order to
effectively categorize and market to and
control
yeah however um something is bizarre
i went back when i was let back into
facebook and began to look at who my
friends on facebook are
um it's pretty interesting there's some
pretty powerful people
in that friend group and i'm sure jordan
will
be able to say the same thing so i have
the sense that there's a battle going on
in facebook and powerful and tech space
powerful yeah
very much so and so anyway this has got
to be super awkward
inside facebook we may never know what's
going on there but well when you
you mentioned this to me uh fair a
couple days ago and you know i said to
you
i think you know maybe there's a power
struggle going on but i think
at least some of these events and maybe
a majority of them maybe a vast majority
of them are attributable to the fact
that in many domains the adults in
charge
have put interns sometimes unpaid
entirely sometimes underpaid
fresh out of college super woke you know
brim
heads brimming with postmodernist
critical race theory
fill in the blank studies here nonsense
in charge of
things like social media feeds and
making decisions
about um about censoring accounts
basically because these are
this this is work that requires a desire
to spend a lot of time in those in those
in those spaces
and also is is kind of wrote but it
turns out that this kind of wrote work
actually has tremendous power
so we've they they we didn't they
um the the would-be adults uh both
seated power in
in parenting and helped create this this
mess
among nearly an entire generation and
uh and now many of the the woke young
are in charge of effectively policing
what we all are allowed to see yeah but
it's even one step
worse than this because you've got that
thread
through which um total nonsense of awoke
stripe has reached a level of uh
you know commonality and acceptance that
it makes it dangerous
but then you have this other thing which
i don't think is inherently closely
related to it
right which is the corrupt
left the technocratic corrupt left
which is attempting to maintain its
power
and my point would be is if you come at
this from the question of well okay what
does a heterodox person
conclude about all of the issues of the
day right
two things they are likely to conclude
uh are
one um that the woke stuff is dangerous
and not true and two that
um the democratic party
is not defending the interests of common
people and is actually
uh a cryptically corrupt force that
maintains the status quo and keeps power
held tightly in a small group
and the point is okay so
the platforms are now inhabited by
people motivated by the former
and owned by people motivated by the
latter
and they've teamed up in this unholy
alliance
and that is the really scary thing
because the kind of power to adjust the
way we think or whether we think
that is contained in the algorithmic
technical layer is
immense yeah no it sure is can we talk
about another scary alliance
wonderful let's talk about another scary
line uh bernie sanders endorsed sarah
iannarone for mayor of portland
yes he did sarah ian around for those of
you not in portland or who have missed
our earlier conversations
is the uh contender for mayor against
uh ted wheeler who is the incumbent
and who has done a mostly just terrible
job
kowtowing to the protesters and the
rioters
and making sure to leave the police with
very little options
in terms of shutting down the violence
that's been happening
in portland where we have a 30-year high
in terms of the
murder rate uh we have you know just it
it's it's been it's been bad and i'll
say a little bit more about that
later um so early in the summer when the
protests
which nightly become riots and have
every single night
since uh they started in the end of may
uh we were thinking well
okay ted wheeler is up for election and
we just had not been paying much
attention to
local the local politics you know that
that was one error that we made
it turns out uh that in the primary sara
iannarone who came in far far
behind ted wheeler came in with enough
votes that a runoff is necessary and now
it's the two of them
in not the most recent poll but a poll
the penultimate poll that was done
ianarone was 11 points ahead in the
mayoral race against wheeler
and this is terrifying
we are now in a position of needing
wheeler who has been bumbling and
incompetent and helped
lead portland to the brink of disaster
we need wheeler to stay in office
because
the the the opposition
is a dangerous loon and now we have
bernie sanders
oh boy endorsing her so let me just
i want to read from a little text
exchange i had with one of her staffers
oh sure um so this you know many
everyone really i'm sure now is getting
these
um unsolicited texts from people saying
hey you're registered whatever you are
um we know that you're going to vote for
hmm and if you if you don't well then
what's wrong with you
so you know we've gotten them for the
democrats the national level
at the state level and at the mural
level and
uh i got something from a staffer for
iannaron
and i'm not going to read the whole
interchange but in the in my
in my final thing to her
i said a strong criminal element is
being allowed to destroy property and
businesses do actual harm to people and
terrorize many in a cloak of anti-racism
and anti-fascism
that looks like a convenient lie to get
people to go along
i can't vote for someone who supports
antifa does iana roan have published
statements on what has been happening in
the streets since george floyd's death
this was in early september the staffer
responded in full quote sarah is a
progressive an
educator and she stands opposed to
fascism the media especially right-wing
outlets love to demonize
sarah because of what she represents a
true challenge to the conservative
establishment who is ready for change
sarah doesn't want america to turn into
an authoritarian state so she opposes
fascism
and calls herself an everyday
anti-fascist like so many of us that
stand opposed to extremism might
sarah is a working-class mom and an
entrepreneur a cyclist and an urban
planner who studied at psu
sarah isn't a radical she's just
unapologetic about being right when
confronted with injustice
that scares people who would rather see
progress fail
i don't i don't even know how much of
this is true like i don't know in what
way anne aron is supposedly an educator
i
looked to back up that claim and i can't
find anything um also on some page i
found she's listed as a professor
at psu and she doesn't even have a phd
so i i honestly don't know
if any of these claims are true i know
she's certainly a schooling wheeler
yes so but yeah bigger bigger than
just trying to fact check this litany of
supposed attributes this woman has
um it's it's the same kind of twisted
language that is passing for logic
on so much of the left right now well we
should also point out for
you know since very few of our our
listeners
are portland residents who will probably
even
know who sarah yanaroon is that's why i
gave a little preamble
right but i mean you know among the
things that she has
done visibly she
broadcast a tweet in which she shows a
photograph of what she says is her
favorite here's how i voted ballot
picture
this is from when she was running for
mayor in 2016 right and people were
sending her pictures of their ballots
where they had voted for her for mayor
and this ballot had had a complete other
slate of people
yes except for the vote for her
they were all write-ins yep and all the
write-ins
were i think stalin was on there three
times
now lennon yeah
angela davis i think was there um it was
it was uh who's who of uh
of castro i believe so
in any case look this is not funny
this is not funny last night i believe
it was last night
the uh perpetual riot
was in vancouver washington just north
of the columbia river here
yeah not vancouver bc it's it's it's
greater portland
a suburb of portland and um anyway
with less tax yeah with no income tax
but
um but anyway the rioters were
in the streets doing something that
they've gotten used to doing
which is um harassing citizens
and insisting uh that they
uh wake up and um
oh we're awake yeah and sleeping with
you guys basically
it's it's a roving menace and i think
the idea
is that at some level they've settled
upon
um spooking one neighborhood after the
next so that people understand there's a
mob in the street and it regards you as
the enemy unless you
make certain noises and so in that
context right to be broadcasting and at
the very least i believe she rebroadcast
this
um this tweeted picture
recently so in the context of the modern
uh of this current electoral cycle um
for her to be playing games with famous
despots
like you know if you're in a friend
group and they know you're really well
and they know that that's the opposite
of who you are
it's one thing to make those jokes it's
another thing entirely
when we are actually watching something
with many
elements of a communist revolution
marching through the streets
intimidating citizens engaged in
violence uh
damaging uh courthouses all of this
stuff that is no moment to be
on the ballot uh running for mayor and
joking about this stuff and
my guess and i guess it's my hope also
is that bernie sanders
got bad info maybe he's got people on
his staff who are
who just think the farther left
something is the better
or maybe he you know somebody looked at
the websites of the various
candidates and she sounded more
progressive because she makes an effort
to do that
and that this was a careless endorsement
yeah
but on the other hand you and i and
several others
tweeted at him yesterday saying this is
a terrible error and you're putting the
people of portland in jeopardy
his endorsement potentially really makes
a difference yeah it's a close race and
the fact is
um in a close race at this scale of
course his endorsement could make
it could make the difference and i don't
know what happens if if biden wins and
iana rhone wins i don't know what
happens to portland but it it isn't
going to be good
nope nope it's not uh so
maybe speaking of our narratives about
portland
and what it is that we understand to be
true as opposed to what is being put
out there in the world the guardian
published an op-ed i think it was today
maybe last night by a woman
who moved to portland from london with
her family in 2015
but finds it not to be the liberal
paradise she was expecting
uh and this here actually i can i can
put it up briefly and then i'll just
read a couple of here we go
um so
we left the uk for portland expecting a
liberal dream that wasn't the reality
uh and so she is south asian presumably
i don't know if she says that in the
in the piece but she talks about being a
brown person which is difficult but
hard easier than being a black person so
she even specifies at that level
and uh apparently her husband here uh
his mom lives in portland
but they moved from london five years
ago and they're really thinking of
moving back
so if i may have my screen back zachary
um
she her take uh is as has been noted
online well written
and i'm sorry well written isn't
sufficient it's it reminds us
it reminds me talking about a take being
well written of
the students of ours who when we would
have them read the selfish gene
uh first up in any number of our
programs
by dawkins would object to it on the
basis of his tone
like you know you can object to his tone
or you could like the way that she
puts words together but we're asking you
to think about the content
and yes the way it's written does have
an effect on how you think about the
content but it can't be first and can't
be the only thing that you have to say
about
it so um she just just took
a few quick quotes she calls uh what has
been going on in
portland predominantly peaceful protests
something with which we are well
familiar
she says small groups who damaged
property grabbed national headlines
alighting the fact that actually there's
been um
a lot more than property damage there's
been there's been
violence to people including killings um
the quote scare quotes the riots were
confined to a couple of blocks downtown
nope not true the protesters were not
threatening portlanders
what no and i imagine that's a kind of a
cryptic dog whistle to the man who was
actually murdered
by the guy who was then killed by police
up near olympia washington was maybe not
a portlander i don't even i don't
remember if that's true but i sort of
imagine that might be what that
little word play is about there quote we
took our seven-year-old to
family-friendly protests
yeah maybe and i'll bet you got out of
there before the sun went down didn't
you
quote meanwhile the police were
threatening so she know she goes through
all of this evidence of how peaceful it
is by simply claiming how peaceful it is
and then she goes into the usual scare
tactics the the fear-mongering
um so it made me wonder you know is this
willful deception or is she legit
legitimately confused and
yeah of course it's both of course she's
involved in she's got deep-seated fear
of other in part actually like she's
she's got the same deep-seated fear of
others she displays when she's talking
about being in
eastern oregon and not wanting to get
out of the car because
you know she reads it as people don't
like the color for skin
um but this this strikes me as as fear
that is
i don't think mostly uh mostly founded
in the state of oregon at this point
like i like it's not mine to say at some
level because
i'm not her and i haven't been traveling
in eastern oregon with my family with
brown skin but
really so this like deep-seated fear
struck me as exactly the same
style of deep-seated fear that actual
white nationalists
have about people who look different
from them um or is it intentionally
selective storytelling and spinning of
what is true
i think it's some of both i think i
think he's got some of both there and
just before you respond
let me just um reread in episode 48 so
four episodes ago i read from the
beginning of my then
brand new essay in the glossy swiss
magazine schweitzer monad
i want to share just the first paragraph
again here um
because um lest you
wonder what i think and i think you
think also is going on in the streets of
portland
it looks like this george floyd died and
you don't have to show it zach george
floyd died under the knee of a police
officer in minneapolis
in the end of may and people spilled
onto the streets of american cities
outraged at police brutality and racial
bias and exhausted by cove at 19
lockdowns
in portland oregon where i lived those
protests turned into riots nearly every
single night last summer
the homicide rate climbed to the highest
it's been in 30 years
one late night in mid-august a man was
dragged from his car and beaten by a
small band of thugs
the next day on a bluebird sky morning
some of the few stores nearby that were
not boarded up had shop owners out on
the sidewalks
cleaning up from the mayhem of the
previous night in this once bustling
downtown
normal human activity is almost entirely
absent while the sun shines
and at night the chaos resumes fires are
started
people are assaulted human feces is
literally thrown around
some would tell you that my mentioning
these facts is evidence that i'm on the
political right
in fact i am and always have been on the
left
so that's my version
her version looks almost nothing like
that
and yet here we are living in the same
city and
it's the negative it's the negative it's
the negative
the photographic negative yeah like the
photographic negative
so i want to point out two things yeah
one i think i know what she's doing
and i think it works like this okay
there is a template there is a narrative
template of what
those who are pushing in this direction
let's take them
uh as honest and wanting
a revolution that they believe will
think make things better i believe they
are crazy
in this assessment but let us imagine
that privately this is what they think
and so
they are sparing nothing in the attempt
to
advance this narrative so the point is
one way to score a
point in their universe is to put
something into the world
that advances this narrative and part of
this narrative is that the counter
narrative is itself
counterfeit right so if you pay
attention to the portland subreddit for
example
this is constant right it is a constant
stream
of things designed to suggest portland
is fine it is being portrayed as not
fined by
right-wing zealots and fascists the
cause is trump
the response is peaceful it's constant
right so here you have i thought you
said it was the counter narrative that
was
that was counterfeit i think i missed
narrative is counterfeit
but inside of that narrative why is it
that you are seeing all this stuff about
something being wrong in portland if in
fact portland is fine and it's a bunch
of peaceful liberals protesting against
federal fascism
oh the answer is that's a right-wing
talking point that's being advanced into
the world it's nonsense you can go
walk out into portland you see any fires
you know this kind of thing
so i believe what she is doing is taking
the template and it's a little bit like
being jumped into a gang
right you're being jumped into a gang
the answer is well
if you're going to be jumped into the
gang you have to i don't know this
phrase
you have to commit these crimes or you
have to endure this beating
or you have to advance this cause or you
have to bring back this
thing whatever it is and so in effect
there is
a set of things that you can do
that make you one of the mob and one of
them is advancing this with whatever
tools you have to bring to bear
and i would point out you've got your
corrective
right you've described what you see you
can compare it to what she sees
and we also have in this case the
marvelous comparison
of what douglas murray saw right because
of course he's coming from london and
douglas murray sat in that very chair
and said
this is not normal yeah i have seen
these things
but i have never seen them in a first
world city right this
is not normal and and you know what he
didn't
well i have not finished listening to
your conversation without this story yet
but when we had dinner with him and what
i have listened to
i don't think he said he's seen even
these things he said he's seen
um journalists worried you know fearful
for their lives and obviously
we we all know that journalists have
been killed but
he i think he said that he hasn't even
seen and he's been a lot of places
with civil unrest um
graffiti advocating for the killing
of a journalist he's talking about andy
noe and
the authorities doing nothing about it
it just being allowed to stand
so that actually was i think you said
novel in his experience yeah i believe
he did say that that was novel in his
experience and
obviously it's a tacit sanction yes um
which is frightening right andy is
among the only people giving a sense for
what's actually going on in portland on
a daily basis
and of course they want to do away with
him because
their whole phony narrative depends on
you not being able to check for yourself
and frankly
you want to know what's going on in
portland look at what's on andy noah's
feed
it's documented it's video right it's
not to say that that's the full picture
exactly
what's on the feed is certainly
happening it's not everything that's
going on in portland
certainly it's been curated but it's not
fabricated
curated but not fabricated curated but
not fabricated and because it is alone
in telling the true story of what's
going on in portland you know the fact
that it's curated it doesn't even begin
to get at what
it's up against with respect to to phony
narrative
yeah so if i can take one little detour
here yeah there's something i wanted to
introduce
which um a friend um
pointed this out in a conversation some
weeks ago and it has
stuck with me there is a scientific
result
that increasingly i think explains one
of the weirdest features
of this modern chaos
which is the tendency of the claims
to be most overblown in places where
they are least likely to be true
right so portland is the site of these
riots over anti-black racism
portland is as liberal as city as exists
in the country
presumably anti-black racism is less
prevalent here than it is almost
anywhere else
why is it happening same thing with
evergreen why was evergreen the site of
this
most incredible set of protests
about uh white supremacy of all places
for white supremacy
uh to be difficult to find you would
imagine evergreen would be top of the
list
and you know for me to be their first
target demonstrates just how difficult
it was to find
just how difficult it was to find so
anyway here's the question
uh zach could you put up the paper that
i sent you
so what this paper describes is an
experiment oh geez i'm not going to be
able to read it
okay any chance you can make a little
bigger and scroll up to the abstract
um the there it goes yep nope
and scroll up so we can see the abstract
there we go so what this paper describes
is an experiment that tested
what people's perception initially about
color
having no connotation whatsoever blue
versus purple
people's perception of color as one
color
in the experiment became increasingly
rare so let me read the abstract to the
extent i can do that from here
do you want me yeah you want to do it i
can see it yeah why do some social
problems seem so intractable
in a series of experiments we show that
people often respond to decreases in the
prevalence of a stimulus by expanding
their concept of it
when blue dots became rare participants
began to see purple dots as blue
when threatening faces became rare
participants began to see neutral faces
as threatening
and when unethical requests became rare
participants began to see innocuous
requests as
unethical this prevalence-induced
concept change
occurred even when participants were
forewarned about it and even when they
were instructed and paid to resist it
social problems may seem intractable in
part because reductions in their
prevalence lead people to see more of
them
wow so this is again like like with the
nom chomsky
interview in the new yorker i've not
seen this before so i i've not read the
paper i can't say
what's in it or this is published you
said 2018 yeah
or maybe you said that to me off air um
so there's probably been time
for rebuttal if there has been time for
a battle and i don't know if there
has been i looked i did not i do not see
it a rebuttal
um amazing it's
amazing so if we can just put this in
context you and i immediately spot in
that abstract
um a claim that if true has
tremendous implications for things like
claims of injustice
in effect what we've got is a
kind of built-in apparently neurological
relativism
that as something becomes rare finds it
where it isn't
now you can imagine that there are all
kinds of reasons that your neurobiology
would have such a feature right imagine
neurological relativism you're searching
for berries right
the berries you will find first are
going to be the ones that are obvious
and right in front of your face
as those get depleted because you've
picked all the good ones you have to
become
increasingly sensitive so diminishing
returns causes your perception
to need to get more sensitive you need
to effectively become
visually very paranoid in order to spot
the one that's halfway hidden by the
leaf
i know yeah it's an incredible phrase
isn't it but visually very paranoid
visually very paranoid yes but okay so
you can imagine that this could result
in you collecting more berries per hour
a kind of
increase in your sensitivity the problem
or it's you've hit that point in the
diminishing returns curve where you
should go
fish instead or go to a totally
different part of the
part of your locality but imagine how
that would play out if you were looking
for barriers right right your
sensitivity goes up
which means you keep finding the ones
that are harder and harder to find and
then eventually
you're seeing phantom berries where they
aren't you're just seeing a shadow or a
dark space in the thing and you're
reaching in and you're getting
nailed by a thorn right the point is
that will that calculation will hit you
too
and it'll be like i keep thinking i'm
gonna get something and there's no
reward i keep thinking i'm gonna get it
no reward no reward right but there's
physical feedback with regard to
visually bury paranoia
right and there's no there's not
inherently
any actual physical feedback when it's
claims that are entirely socially
constructed around
i am sure that he said that to me
because he's racist right
so what you've got is a system that has
i think an objective analysis would tell
you that there was a great deal of
racism
at the founding of the country even
people who wanted to know better
still didn't right and that the degree
to which racism is a commonly
encountered phenomenon has dropped
dramatically and that at this point in
history
we are in objective terms far better off
than we were with respect to this thing
that we all agree is bad
however and not only that but better
than most of the world
better than most of the world and we all
know what the goal is which is
zero racism right so that's an amazing
degree of
progress but the point is what it
accompanies is a decrease
in actual examples of racism that you
encounter
which if this paper is right and general
which it
suggests it seems to be by virtue of the
fact that they weren't just looking at
colors they were looking at things like
perceptions of threat and uh perceptions
of injustice
yeah that what this suggests is that as
the phenomenon in question becomes
increasingly rare
people will find it where it isn't yeah
which
raises rather directly the specter that
microaggressions and
every analog of them is going to be
formulated as you approach zero with
respect to this being a common
phenomenon
right and so what will that look like
well it will certainly in
a case where let's say there was zero
racism in policing and i'm not saying
that there is
but let's say that we reached zero right
there would still be
bad shootings and things because to have
people enforcing the law with guns
guarantees there will be a certain
number of bad shootings we'll hit
something close to zero racism and
policing before we will hit
zero errors in violence in policing
right
and then what you would predict is that
people will read into
events that actually weren't bad
shootings or events that were bad
shootings but were not racially biased
they will read into it exactly this
thing
and that of course could derange
civilization especially if you had an
online amplification mechanism for
these things so um you know think about
the term
white supremacy right white supremacy
was a thing that
everybody would have agreed was
vanishingly rare 15 years ago
because we all understood it to be
something pretty dramatic right it
wasn't just garden variety racism it was
an aggressive
belief structure that you know crosses
burning on lawns in this kind of thing
and gosh i want to say every but let's
just say
nearly every elected official in the
united states would have been proud to
get up and say
obviously i oppose white supremacists
obviously obviously right it's the most
obvious thing in the world
and now we're getting to the point where
the absence
of overt white supremacy right the
relegating of that
ugly terrible phenomenon to a tiny
number of people on
the fringe that doesn't matter right
that thing
is now being read into all kinds of
stuff right
structural racism and your failure to
say anything about it is the equivalent
of
white supremacy which is insane
right so i would argue um first of all
we need to take the terms back
white supremacy i would argue that there
is a floor a natural floor based on
the common parliament's interpretation
of
the words that a white supremacist
should
by definition at the very least have to
be
rooting for white people to rule over
others
they would have to be rooting for white
people to win right and that means that
it can't be
a feature of a structure right it can't
be a feature if you
are somebody who doesn't want to see uh
one race win
over other races then that to me
suggests you can't be white supremacist
it doesn't mean you can't be
ignorant it doesn't mean that you can't
be part of the problem
right you could be you could be ignoring
important patterns but
that term would seem to suggest an a
desire to see something
rather than just a an indifference to it
yeah
i mean there's there's a lot more to be
explored here one of
my concerns with what you just said
though is that there
is widespread conflation between
individuals and populations
right that that most people actually
don't understand when they have
jumped that giant gap between talking
about an individual versus talking about
a population
and um while that i find egregious and
really we should be educating people
much much better such that people
understand the distinction between an
individual and population level analysis
and
level of responsibility uh what is less
surprising to me
is that well maybe actually more
more surprising in some ways is uh that
scientists themselves contribute to this
to this confusion
and i i
i actually don't think i'm gonna go here
now i think i i don't i don't
quite agree with you are saying we need
the terms back because
i think i have been interested in
getting for instance the term feminism
back for a long time and i sort of i
sort of gave up
you know i've been calling long before
we were ever on any sort of national
stage i was calling what has been
passing for feminism since the mid 90s
faux feminism faux feminism
and you know with candy on the stage
taking so much you know
collecting so many resources and having
so much power
i just i just don't know if it's
possible to take these terms back and
this
and the distinction i guess and this is
what i was going to say
that um you know can if an individual
can be a white supremacist
does it necessarily follow that an
organization cannot be
i don't think it necessarily follows but
i do think that
it is absolutely necessary to whenever
you're making that leap
from a category that applies to
individuals and you are now applying it
to
to structures to systems to populations
to organizations
to be clear that that is what you are
doing and that it therefore may not hold
so this
therefore may be an illegitimate move
because evolutionary processes don't
work
on the same in the same way between
individuals and populations
well okay a couple things one let me
clarify
it's not i obviously don't want to take
the term white supremacy back i don't
want
it right what i want that's not what
you're saying right i want to corral
the term uh to a reasonable
standard and the important thing that we
are seeing i think
we are seeing it overtake quality
thought
across the board is a
demotion of intent
as relevant to the assessment of
a the presence of a thought pattern and
so
you know for for chomsky to say that
trump is the
greatest criminal in human history and
for his explanation to be that he
doesn't care about intent the point is
the hazard
right this is garbage thinking yeah but
i actually think the opposite is also
happening
and it's it's causing maybe more harm
even that you know
chomsky can say intent doesn't matter
but well for god's sake that's just so
obviously wrong and now obviously things
that have been obviously wrong are now
accepted so
we should still be paying attention but
uh i think this is a good segue to
talking about the
so-called karen act in san francisco
the acronym stands for caution against
racially and exploitative
non-emergencies and it's obviously named
for this
epithet against white women uh who are
you know middle class upper middle class
white women who are understood to be
racially biased and calling the police
on black men mostly when they shouldn't
be um
so oh boy this so this
this was just voted on the san francisco
board of supervisors unanimously passed
this
on october 27th and
let's see here we have this is just the
abc
reporting on it zach um san francisco
leaders voted to crack down on so-called
karen's he used 911 calls to
discriminate against minorities so
even the abc reporting of it
acknowledges
the use of this really gross epithet we
aren't allowed to use other epithets for
good reason but newly created ones
against
um groups who have been historically
understood to be in power even when they
actually
um okay so take this off this is too
distracting
thank you um
oh boy it is now somehow okay
the actual ordinance amends the city's
police code and allows anyone harmed by
calls that are racially motivated to sue
so who's to decide whether or not a call
was racially motivated now we
are mind-reading intent into 9-1-1
calls and anyone is going to think twice
about making a 9-1-1 call
if they have an ability to see that
they're that the
person who they would be calling against
is a
different race from them this is this is
going to have an effect that is actually
um dangerous oh yeah and so this this is
mind reading intent this is
this is prioritizing intent as opposed
to pretending that intent doesn't matter
at all so
it's all very slapdash and whatever
serves our particular goals at the
moment
um so let me say that in the three
months
between when this ordinance was first
proposed and when it was accepted
they solicited feedback from the
community
and there were two emails that i found
and going through this that i found
that i thought were just pointed that
that exactly described what the problem
with this
is and i will say that most of the
feedback most of it was negative
but the vast majority of it objected
only to the name
only to the epithet and not to the
actual ordinance
and the epithet is nasty and gross and
what the hell were they thinking but
it's hardly the biggest problem here and
indeed virginia just passed a very
similar bill
um that they didn't give a crazy name
it's called hb5098 on hate crimes
um in which it's a misdemeanor to
knowingly give a false report to a law
officer but that becomes a felony
if that knowing false report is because
of
the the person that you think was
perpetrating it is in any of these
protected classes so
that's super dangerous and virginia just
did the same thing
that's what the san francisco bill um
has has done and uh or ordinance not
bill
um wrote one person into the san
francisco board of supervisors during
the
open discussion period this is one
liberal democrat
saddened that fellow democrats are so
blunted and blinded in their grievance
that they wish to simply rearrange the
parameters of institutional racism
rather than work to eliminate it sounds
familiar does it not
yes the turning the tables of oppression
rather than ending oppression
exactly and this one just a bit longer
but even more on point i think
the proposed karen act is a bad idea in
most cases it is nearly impossible to
prove beyond a reasonable doubt that a
call is racially motivated
this creates incredibly dangerous gray
area in our legal system that can easily
be abused
it will also cause more division in our
communities as people will undoubtedly
read bias into the rulings
this will drive a wedge between the
racial groups of our city and create
prejudice where not existed previously
as groups start to blame each other for
erroneous convictions
we are already dealing with this issue
when it comes to police brutality we
don't need to add more fire to that pot
it will also promote segregation between
racial groups as the potential for
negative interactions
start to carry more dramatic
consequences it will become safer to
just avoid other racial groups that will
be worth it to work together
it will also create an incentive for
criminals to target other races
because they will be able to claim
racial discrimination if a person calls
the cops on them
and the cops arrive before a crime is
committed the criminal can easily say i
wasn't trying to do x y z the caller is
obviously racist
this reminded me so much of the emails
that you were sending
in the 2016-2017 school year at
evergreen
just each of these points are ones that
you were making with regard to the
changes that were being proposed
and and passed at evergreen it's the
same
garbage it's the same same it's the same
playbook
and the worst part which was mentioned
in here is
that this effectively uh creates
a multi-tiered and now you can argue
that there's always been a multi-tiered
uh set of penalties and permissions
inside the law but we all understood it
was a bad thing
yeah right this builds it in so that the
fact is
you know hey it's basically painting a
target
on white women right because the point
is
uh the chances that you have you have an
extra set of defenses
that you can use in this case if you're
black and you want to attack a white
woman then you have an extra set of
legal questions that can be used to
um to muddy waters and so so let me just
like i don't know how to do it for the
people who are just listening but
um but for people watching if we had
this sort of ranked
list of you know demographic characters
that you
that you have had that gave you full
protection from the law and
historically like white men were at the
top and white women were
were second and you know black men were
at the bottom it was kind of like this
and it's been moving right and us
liberals want this to go flat
and it's been moving and it looks like
they want it to do this
absolutely so it's not let's just let's
just overcorrect a little bit no
they're trying to flip it they're trying
to put
the previous the previous demographic
indicators
that cause people so much harm deaths
all of this into the position of power
and privilege
and that's not what democracy should
should be searching for
yes and they are using the informal
and discretionary aspects built into
everything to do it
right so obviously the law here
reads uh oh yes racially motivated uh
calls are you know now going to be uh
penalized
well that was already there except that
what you've done
is you've added a particular slant right
yeah um
you know you calling 9-1-1 falsely is
already a crime so
anyway they're using this discretion and
the thing is
you know as i've said before it's
effectively
uh reparations built into every
interaction
at every scale every day of
the year and you know this is not a
viable solution to the problem even if
you
are strongly in favor of reparations you
can't do it this way yep
um and yet here we are and yet here we
are
we are um we are past our hour mark
and um unless you have something more
i thought i would before
before i read from a tiny bit of this
book
just a page of this book do you have
anything more that you want to talk
about today besides you know
everything uh nope i think we have we
have done a decent
first pass on everything on everything
on everything we chose to talk about so
um this is cynical theories uh by
uh so i'm just gonna look up the
subtitle here cynical theories
how activist scholarship made everything
about race gender and identity and why
this harms everybody
written published this year by our
friends helen plecos and james lindsay
uh it is uh it has experienced some
um some weird machinations on amazon you
know they don't seem to really
like it that much um so you know it you
know less so than abigail schreier's
book
reconcilable differences but um still
you know a bit
a bit down downplayed and downgraded
in um in the public eye i highly
recommend it
i admit that i have not read all of it
but i've dipped into it and it is
exactly the
remarkable resource that i expected it
would be at the point that they were
telling us they were writing this
so at the very end they have
um just a few what they say as a few
examples of how you can recognize social
injustice
while rejecting the solutions the
ideology of social justice proposes
so they've got a number of principled
opposition examples
example one being we affirm
that racism remains a problem in society
and needs to be addressed
we deny that critical race theory and
intersectionality provide the most
useful tools to do so
since we believe that racial issues are
best solved through the most rigorous
analyses possible
we contend that racism is defined as
prejudiced attitudes and discriminatory
behavior against individuals or groups
on the grounds of race and can be
successfully addressed as such
we deny that racism is hard baked into
society via discourses
that it is unavoidable and present in
every interaction to be discovered and
called out
and that this is part of a ubiquitous
systemic problem that is everywhere
always and all pervasive we deny that
the best way to deal with racism is by
restoring social significance
to racial categories and radically
heightening their salience
and finally we contend that each
individual can choose not to hold racist
views
and should be expected to do so that
racism is declining over time and
becoming rarer
that we can and should see one another
as humans first and members of certain
races second that issues of race are
best dealt with by being honest about
racialized experiences
while still working towards shared goals
and a common vision
and that the principle of not
discriminating by race should be
universally upheld
excellent as you would expect from those
two as you'd expect from those too
yeah um oh and i guess actually one
one more thing we wanted to do today um
if i can turn this into a link and then
have you show my screen zachary um
is a totally different topic um
we are here in portland as we have
mentioned
many times and in response
to the virtual schooling that looks like
it may go on endlessly
and the fact that some of the public
schooling options are not
doing a very good job of educating a
couple of friends of ours
are starting in an alternative school
what they're calling a pod but um it's
wilding academy and it's here on the
screen and we'll put a link in the
description as well
and um it's for basically 12 to 15 year
olds
uh let's see yeah
um 12 to 15 year olds sort of late
middle school early high school
uh it's gonna be based out in gresham
but with a lot of outdoor time
we are considering whether or not to
have our younger son
move out of his public school situation
and into this but regardless of whether
or not we do that
our friends sam and robin who are
starting this up um
are i think are going to do an excellent
job and we encourage anyone with kids of
that age in the portland area who are
thinking
um that they might want something
different for their kids educationally
to look into it yep
gold and opportunity yeah yeah all right
we have reached the uh the end of the
first portion
of darkhorse podcast live number 52.
yes we have so we will be coming back in
15 minutes to answer your superchat
questions that you asked this hour and
next you as always can join us on our
patreons
online to get access to a private q a
every month the last sunday of the month
on brett's uh in one of a couple of
things are to join him for
small conversations uh the first of this
month is tomorrow
or tomorrow at 10 a.m if you are
an attendee of that conversation zoom
did something funny when i created the
uh the schedule
which is it corrected in advance for
daylight savings time so the time reads
incorrectly in the invite but it's 10
o'clock am tomorrow
as if it imagines you're counting up
hours as opposed to you know when it is
in the schedule anyway i
created it five times to make sure i
wasn't making an error and it did it
every time so
okay so but it's going to be 10 a.m as
usual for two hours um there's a discord
server that you could access to at other
patreons
uh the dark horse podcast clips channel
is producing
clips almost daily at this point so
subscribe to that too if uh and if
there's if there are clips that you
particularly like to see
from any of these uh episodes you can
contact the moderator at darkhorse
moderator is that the web is that the
email address
i think i don't remember i'm sorry um
and we will see you in 15 minutes all
right be well everyone